bonjour et bienvenue sur des modèles tv
pour suivre cette grande finale du
championnat du monde féminin 2015 finale
qui vont s'affronter natalia pogonat la
russe face à l'ukrainienne maria musi
tchouk donc match et en quatre parties
quatre parties longues avant d éventuels
tie break
nous allons voir tout de suite comment
débute cette finale avec les blancs pour
natalia pogo ni dans la première et elle
débute pas des quatre des cinq donc on
rentre à priori dans un gambit dame dont
la c4 et c6 encore une fois une slave
donc c'est ce fameux coup c6 qui décide
que l'on est dans une une slave
on a vu plein de fois les joueuses jouer
aussi soucis dans ce championnat
qu'avait laissé trois caves à nice 2-3
tous et très connu e 6 voilà slave
fermer la regarder alors je dis fermé
parce que voilà bombay ont renoncé à
sortir le fou si vite
voilà temporairement en général on a vu
souvent dans ce championnat aussi des
libérations rapides des noirs par la
sortie du pion ici sur la case e 5 après
une préparation mais entendu le fou noir
on le sort on met la dame 1,7 en moyenne
17 et au bon moment on joue e5 ce qui va
enfin libère le fou ces huit cavaliers
froid qu'elle est 17ème ces deux coups
des six fou détroit regardez comme les
deux camps se développe à la fois
rapidement mais aussi précisément en
jouant les pièces sur leur meilleure
case petit rock petit rock prise en c4
vous prend
et b5 alors bien que c'est un autre plan
que ce qu'on a vu je pense une autre
idée c'est de jouer dams est qu'on a vue
d'un an 1,7 et jouer aux cinq la poussée
centrale qu'on a vu souvent pour la b5
on attaque le fou est à 6 donc là on
consolide et on peut envisager de jouer
pourquoi passer cinq maintenant un c'est
pour ça que je vois si c'est pour bien
protéger des cinq et on peut envisager
des ses singles et ses protégés par le
cavalier par le fou dans quatre prisons
reprend par exemple du cavalier et on a
libéré la grande diagonale ici pour le
fou de cases blanches tour d un bon
alors déjà donc ça neutralise un tout
petit peu c'est celle parce que après
prise et la reprise du travail ou du
faux bon au moins on a mis la vie tour
dames possible il peut se passer des
petites bricoles donc on peut retarder
voilà on préfère mètres d'avancé 7 e 4
alors voilà un coût qui neutralise
encore une fois c'est scène puisque je
menace ou 5 et fourchettes fou cavalli
donc là voilà le coup et e5 de nouveau
ici 5
mais quand alors on a joué à six baies
-celles bon on est un peu affaibli le
pion c6 alors c'est l'une des idées des
blancs symbole en plus ce sont là deux
pions contre heures au centre bon ça
c'est mon premier point mais ce pion ici
bon si on sort le fou je pense j'ai 5
par exemple donc jour le tour en c1 hop
on a deux pièces lourdes contre le pion
c6 sur une colonne semi ouverte voilà
c'est typiquement le la définition même
de pions arriérés un pion faible voilà
c'est si c'est une est une cible
voilà plus on prend de celle là il
fallait faire quelque chose avec les
blancs cavaliers prend alors attention à
l'audace noirs ici ses cavaliers pros f3
échec au roi suivi de fou proche de
échec puis on retire le fou et on a
gagné un pion on est donc h3c explique
le coup suivant
tours 8 l'art déco manque aux solides
ici la case 5 ha et on vise derrière le
pion eu 4 ou g5
alors ça c'est un bon coup de
développement du fou est sur une bonne
case puisqu'il menace à tout moment de
prendre le khalife 6 en cassant un petit
peu la structure du roi noir mais
regardez les noirs joue cavalier prend
vous prend et la foux 6 ça c'est un coup
étonnant parce qu'on n'a pas peur de se
faire doubler les pions alors qu'est ce
qui se serait passé si ici les blancs
avaient doublé les pions noirs c'est
possible bien entendu de prendre 26 les
noirs dans ce cas-là reprennent en 9,6
et on a effectivement au roi un peu dans
les courants d'air alors ceci on n'a
plus le fou de casement puisqu'on vient
de donner donc on peut envisager pour
les noirs un plan de type 3 h 8 puis
tour g8 et commencer à viser le roi
blanc par exemple autres l'idée
peut-être un peu lent parce que le faust
rond en plus est bien placé pour
protéger notre idée c'est de jouer f5 au
centre vu qu'on contrôle bien la case e
5 avec dame est fou on jouait 5 tôt ou
tard pour pas tout de suite pascal adam
qui contrôle mais au bon moment jouer
cinq et on s'échange contre le pion aux
4 et ça élimine le pion doublé alors à
noter quand même aussi en compensation
de ses pions de doubler les noirs ont
deux choses un bond des sites de pions
là quand même contrôle bien disons le ce
pion eu qu'à se tuant quatre aura pas
avancer bien loin parce qu' ils se
heurtent à nice espèce de barbelés là si
vous vous laissez ses deux pions ici
c'est très difficile à passer avec des
pions et puis les noirs ont la fameuse
paire de fou surtout voilà ses environs
les deux fous et pas les blancs donc la
paire de fou en finale c'est une arme
extrêmement puissante qui contrebalance
très très souvent un petit désavantage
soit deux structures pouvoir même
souvent en avant
des avantages matériels à long terme et
avec un pur de moins la paire de fou on
s'en sort très bien
voilà donc alors faut aussi sinon voilà
on n'a pas peur de se faire doubler les
pions pourquoi pas donc tour à ses
heures c'est ce que j'avais dit fleurs
voilà puisse londres et le pion 6,6 à
noter aussi qu'on a le force 3 à tout
moment peuvent eux on peut envisager de5
attaque alors
et surprise on pourrait ensuite se
venger sur pioncer 6 points alors là la
menace des blancs sans doute c'est de
jouer le cavalier soit en b1 soit eux
deux plus probablement pour menacer de
venir en d4 par exemple et en deux ans
menace avec dame et tour d'aller prendre
le pion c6 arriérés mais tour des huit
on n'a pas peur avec les noirs regardez
on protège même pas le pion 6 6 à 8
alors ça alors une des idées c'est que
si les blancs essayé d'attaquer le pion
ces six bombes et il y a toujours des
manoeuvres possible du type fou échec
par exemple aura bougé en échange une
paire de tours donc en cas de reprise de
la tourbe et on a plus on aura plus de
pièces contre le pion voyez donc une
phase est une façon indirecte de
soulager le pion c6 d'échanger une paire
de tours b3 très bons coups b3 logique
bon j'enlève déjà une case au fou aussi
ce donc je joue contre ça ça ne vous
contre le x 600 premiers points ça lui
enlève des cases ya pas de gaza tout
simplement regarder toutes les cases ou
pourrait aller se fout sont contrôlés
par par des pions blancs
voilà tout ça est pris par pur mais on
peut même mettre en je vais mettre un
rouge je les regardais le voir ce genre
de choses
regardez comme ses pions voilà jouent
tous contre le fou au cices voilà les
pions sur blanc empêche le fo'o 6,2 de
bouger il est il est vissé ce pion ce
fou par an donc en jouant b3 on enlève
descazeaux fou c'est le premier point et
on libère le cavalier aussi parce que
bon il y avait peut-être à deux ans
prise alors bon jamais vraiment ce que
si j'enlève le cavalier le fou aux 6
prend à deux mais simplement je
l'enferment par b3
toujours à voir ça en tête on peut
enfermer les fous qui comme ça vont
aller à la pêche aux pions alors une
partie extrêmement célèbre sur ce thème
qu'il faut absolument voir parce que
c'est elle est très belle et elle est
surtout historique c'est la fameuse
partie du match entre fischer espace qui
c'est une des premières parties je sais
pas si c'est pas là la deuxième ou la
troisième je sais plus où fischer prend
le pied au h22 spassky dans une finale
c'est même une finale il s'est enfermé
le fou prendre le fou pour deux pions et
finalement ce pas ce qui finit par
l'emporter
tout le monde s'est demandé si fischer
avait tout calculé ci s'est pas trompé
et c est en fait il avait dit après la
partie qu'il avait joué comme un idiot
donc en fait il a ici complètement il
s'était complètement plantée il n'avait
pas vu que le fou pouvait se faire
enfermer voyez donc ça arrive même aux
champions du monde
voilà donc voyez cette partie c'est
typique de cette idée d'aller prendre
des pions empoisonnait bel est fou comme
ça on se fait enfermer plus difficile
d'affirmer les cavaliers mais on y
arrive aussi parfois donc il faut faire
attention comme ça les pions loigné
comme ça donc fouache deux échecs
alors ça c'est un peu ce qu'on avait dit
voilà on fait un petit échec tour eiffel
est maintenant à tout moment on peut
échanger une paire de tourin pas obligé
de le faire tout de suite
regardez simplement voilà on met le fou
en 5 alors pourquoi avoir fait un échec
d'abord au rabais on aurait pu jouer
phocéenne tout de suite mais l'idée
c'est qu'on déstabilise un peu le roi il
aurait pu choisir venir à chanas car il
se serait éloigné du centre en prévision
d'une finale ultérieure à vaux mieux que
le roi adverse soit loin ça lui fait
perdre un temps et s'il se rapproche du
centre
vu qu'on n'est pas encore un final il
peut s'avérer faible cercle maintenant
il surclasse blanche
par exemple si un jour cette diagonale
s'ouvre bon c'est pas le cas tout de
suite mon avis
on a vu ce fou été dominés mais si un
jour cette grande diagonale s'ouvre et
bien un petit échec ça peut pas faire de
valets parfois ça permet de faire des
combinaisons tactiques qui arrive au bon
moment
voilà donc on met le roi en tout cas ici
way bien que ce roi est un peu moins en
sécurité qu'en juin où il était même à
l'abri de tout échec
voilà là il ya un petit échec possible
sur cette diagonale est faux et 3
tranquillement on revienne alors je suis
allé trop loin la voile a fait 3 voilà
on revient avec le fou qu'est ce qui
s'est passé on attendait parce que j'ai
joué quoi j'ai joué à la fois je dois je
crois enfin fou au sein voilà faut 3
c'est sa faute 3 le four revient dans
trois très bien noté contrôler la casse
ces cinq cases d'avancé du pion ainsi le
pion bouge pour ce serait possible que
l'on pourrait venir ans et qu'à protéger
par le fou mais fou et deux espions va
en faire le siège et on va échanger en
c4 on va faire le siège de ce point
voilà donc on revient c'est parti h 6 h
une fois que le fou et venues entre eux
mais non je veux aussi ci reviendra pas
angers 5 alors l'appareil on enlève une
case au faou et en même temps bon on se
prémunit aussi on se donne du mal du
couloir voilà il ya plus le match du
couloir bon petite fenêtre vous
connaissez ça toujours pas agréable de
se faire planter un maître du couloir en
fait une variante kallio 2 up
alors ça c'était l'idée qu'on avait dit
sur b3 notamment sa libérer le cavalier
même s'il faut prendre à deux semblait
pas bon puisque b3 et le fou est en
prise mais bon ça on a enlevé descazeaux
fou à noter qu'au regard des ja pas fou
c'est 4 par exemple ces quatre auraient
pu être jouées clouant le camaïeu 2 par
exemple avec b3 on ne peut pas le faire
son cavalier e 2 on peut menacer
maintenant devenir en d4 et pourquoi pas
attaquer le fou et surtout surtout le
fameux puis on sait si ce qui commence à
être sous pression là c'est le premier
noir dans cette position tout reprend
voyez on soulage tout reprend tour croit
voilà c'est ce qu'on avait dit tout à
l'heure aussi on a échangé une paire de
tours donc tout de suite il ya plus que
la dame canton 6,6 il n'y a plus il n'y
a plus la dame et la tour s'il n'y a
plus qu'une seule pièce donc c'est
beaucoup moins faible fou s'est vite
alors poussé 8 vu qu'on a vu qu'on
n'arriverait pas empêché ce cavalier
devenir par exemple en d4
l'attaquant sait s'ils sont bien ces
huit évitant de se faire attaquer le fou
et si lecavalier vient des quatre on
peut envisager par exemple ou b cette
voie là même si c'est qu'il est derrière
ses pions le fou mais bon c'est si ses
protégés projet a regardé comme le roi
d'ailleurs ici revient j'avais pourquoi
est il des idées noires ça peut être
aussi de bouger ses pions 1 to ou tard
un jour et le fou pour revenir à 6 avec
un échec
bon courage à eux c'est un coup ou
prophylactiques n ya pas de vraie menace
mais c'est un coût qui prévient des
échecs ultérieure foulée cette voie là
deux voiliers comme le foot bombay il a
vu qu'il avait plus d'avenir ici les
blancs ont bougé leurs plans pour jouer
contre ce fou maintenant il va chercher
de l'air de sur cette diagonale là et là
c'est pas la même parce que le pion aux
quatre lits sous pression regarder avec
cavalli m6 et la truite est
potentiellement le fou bessette aussi
voilà il suffit d'enlever le fou ou 5 et
essayer ce pion et ce pion et en l'air
voilà donc voyez ça m'habite
donc j'ai trois alors pourquoi j'ai
trois ça joue aussi contre le pion 5
contre le fu scène par dont on peut
jouer fou g2 et éventuellement aux
besoins attention faudra bien réfléchir
parce qu'il ya quand même
mais fou ici qui attaquent g3 mais on
pourrait envisager à terme de jouer f3
et qui crée un petit mur face aux fauves
et cette voix là c'est un coût qui ont
pas vraiment très affaiblie sans en
avoir le fond g2c classique devant un
fond parce que le fou de protège
remplace le pion devant le moins donc
c'est comme leur horaire est bien
protégé tour des huit voilà les noirs
allège la position aussi les pièces
courtes soit échangé les c6 sera
vraiment plus faible du tout puisqu'il
n'est faible que s'il ya des pièces
lourdes
donc moi y en a moins il est faible pour
prendre à me prendre là c'est fini peut
plus considérer ces six faible
maintenant parce que fait qu'ils soient
sur une colonne ouverte que la dame bons
essais s'est passé quoi pour pour le
mettre sous pression ou g2
tranquillement alors là une des idées
des blocks ici de s'activer par f4
pourquoi pas le 5 mai ça serait
affaiblie sans attention pour laurent
pour éviter de s'affaiblir comme ça même
si on est en finale et qu'on peut
estimer que le roi ne risque pas grand
chose attention fou c'est cette cabane f
4k il est cette manoeuvre calais des
trois foulées 6 très bien joué fourbe et
si je vaux pause au fouet 3,1 à noter
que cette diagonale est sympa bon voila
j'ai changé des pièces encore une fois
plus en échange toujours approche du nul
possible avec les noirs dans un
championnat du monde c'est un bon
résultat mais entendu qu à l essai scène
pour les blancs regardez comment
verrouille cette caste c5
l'idée de bien tenir cette case c'est de
bloquer le pion sait si c'est ce qui
fait que ça neutralisent complètement le
foot des sept îles et voilà se fout bien
entendu mais il est derrière ses pions
dont il n'a pas de jeu voilà il peut pas
elle peut pas s'activer qu'elle et ses 5
pouces et 8
attention le cavalier le foot est
attaqué aussi calais prend 17 faut
prendre 17
fous ces 5 voilà on continue à
verrouiller la casse ces cinq fonds
prend d'en prendre alors finale dames
fou contre dame ou égalité de pions
alors seule petite chose les blancs sans
doute on petit avantage du fait que les
pions noirs sont sur case blanche
justement donc ce sont des cibles bien
les pions blancs aussi son classement
oui mais c'est plus difficile d'aller
chercher le pion à deux que le pion sait
s'ils sont regardés eux 5 et ça y est
fou plus d'âme attaque le pion facile à
défendre il suffit de mettre la dame en
défense bon illégalité de pions dame est
fou les rois sont pas spécialement en
danger je dirais quand même peut-être
que les blancs sont un tout petit peu
mieux du fait que l'option c6 est faible
et que le fou g2 est très bien placé en
plus on a ici quatre pions contre 3
si on imaginait par exemple en tous sens
les pions qu'on arrive à échanger ce
pion eu 4 contre le pion à vii pas
reniée par des manoeuvres bombay le roi
sera quand même
en difficulté notamment un faible sur
case blanche bon mais c'est pas le cas
on voit pas trop comment les blancs pour
arriver à faire ça parce que pour jouer
eux 5 e 6 mafia le fou qui protège donc
pour affaiblir ça va pas être simple
mais le fait qu'ils aient des faiblesses
à 6 c 6 pourrait faire basculer les
noirs en défense et on pourrait après
derrière essayer d'affaiblir le roi noir
donc petit avantage blanc mais vraiment
extrêmement léger un extrait traitements
légers bon pas de quoi non plus espérer
un gain damas cinq à 3 à 3 je commence
avec le pion sur noir saveur la couleur
opposée du fou et puis bien sûr
j'empêche dame prend 1,2 fou de 6 e 5 5
c'est ce qu'on a dit on n'a pas peur que
les noirs prennent b3 puisqu'on va se
venger sur ces 6 alors du coup bon ben
on a échangé la faiblesse ses 6 contres
le pion de v 3 c'est pas forcément une
mauvaise idée d'emmener un échec
roy h2 à noter que la dame ici protège
le pion f2 il vaut mieux ne pas
affaiblir c'est son roi fou prend b3 fou
prend 6,6
la position a changé un peu de nature
ici puisque la faiblesse c6 a disparu
mais contre le pion b3 c'est une bonne
opération pour les noirs ils ont
toujours des pions sur blanc donc c'est
faible mais faut faire attention avec
les blancs parce que si les noirs elle
va pousser ses pions et échanger un de
ses deux pions contre le pire à trois
ils auraient un pion passé en plus un
pion pas s'est éloigné un petit peu
comme ça sur le côté et là ça serait les
noirs qui hurlent avantage donc il faut
que les blancs fasse attention à sa fin
et six touchés 2 dans me2 d'un v6
attaque le pion à 6 voilà les blancs
n'ont jamais laissé les noirs toucher
facilement d'un v6 attaque les pions à 6
et
dessein d'en prendre 5 en donne le pion
5 et après dans prend 1,6 la position
est symétrique il n'y a plus rien trois
pions contre trois pions contre-courant
b5 et peut-être un tout petit peu faible
mon âme ses cinq attaques f2 damas six
échecs 3h 7 et les deux joueuses conclu
la partie nulle il n'y a rien à tirer de
cette position et noir vont sans doute
jouer b4 ensuite il arrive de qui
attaque et que ce qu'on fait si on
jouera gm sans doute échec puis on
revient ces 5 et 6 les blancs défendre
par dame f300 nous doumbé 4 et c'est
fini fort n'ont plus rien à espérer il
pourra rien se passer dans cette finale
voilà donc première partie de ce
championnat du monde une jolie partie
pas de aucune précision ni faute jolie
gambie dan défense lab très bien joué
par les noirs qui qui était légèrement
en défensif mais sans créer de fautes et
puis les blancs n'ont pas trouvé de plan
pour mettre en difficulté les noirs donc
les deux joueuses round d'observation on
peut dire et donc partage des points
logique donc rendez vous pour la
deuxième partie revanche ou donc mariam
use it should cette fois aura les blancs
voilà merci de m'avoir suivi sur des
modalités pour ce championnat du monde
2015 pour cette première partie de la
finale et je vous donne rendez-vous donc
pour la suite
au revoir